hi my name is Charlie McDonnell and this
is a packet of wine gums wine gums or
wine gums are chewy firm sweets similar
to gum drops except they are not
sugar-coated they are manufactured from
and all gelatin mix with sweeteners
flavorings and colorings Charlie
McDonnell why are you telling me all
this information about wine gums
recently a friend of mine called Alex
day also known as Mary Mon bought a
packet of wine gums short after buying
this tube of wine guns my friend Alex
realized that he had been shortchanged
you would expect the five different
flavors to be evenly distributed
throughout the pack below cuz when my
friend opened his packet of wine gums he
was distressed to see that he had one
green one red and the rest of the packet
contained yellows and oranges so on this
day Charlie McDonnell myself has decided
to do what I am calling the wine gum
experiments so what I'm going to do is
I'm going to open all these packets and
wine guns I'm going to count the
different numbers of different colors in
the packets and I'm going to draw a
graph of my results because I'm a dork
yay so um what are we doing Jesus Christ
I just want to pour 10 packets of wine
gums I'm not even gonna eat these first
packet of the day and we haven't got a
single green how distressing hi
everybody and welcome to another episode
of Charlie wastes his time this is
exactly the kind of pack that I had
recently two orange ones and not a
single yard as fall apart oh my god
not a single blank how horrible oh
that's disgusting to look at that is my
god look another one no black ones oh
okay here are my results which you can't
see because the light is too bright but
I will now calculate our results and
make a graph because I'm cool so instead
of making a graph a little Peter I
thought I would make a graph out of the
wine gums probably won't eat them now
but yeah it's interesting to see first
we're gonna start off with the bad
points blanks legs are commonly known to
be the best of all of the wine gums the
best tasting wine gums out
they're right any one of these blanks we
have exactly the same number of the
others ingredients which i think is very
interesting hold on
there we go that's better obviously this
is only from ten packs so I can't draw a
distinct conclusion but I've decided
from this point onwards whenever I buy a
pack of wild herbs I will count how many
different colors there are in each
packet and add to my results I've made
today and we shall see how fair male art
actually is these have been on my floor
and when I was putting them out I
noticed there were a number of hairs on
my floor not sure if they were pubic or
not but I probably won't need these
which is a shame but you know it's all
for the good of science right why is
this such an issue here in Britain I
mean I'm sure most of the Americans
probably start watching this over near
the beginning but to British people this
matters right this is important there
are so little black ones right and this
is so disheartening because they have
the nicest ones just took my hoodie on
my hat off because it was getting a bit
hot I think that the only way I'm going
to make this video worthwhile is if I
eat all of these right now do you dare
me what really
it'll probably may be sick you still
okay
I tell you what I really really hope my
mum then come in and watch you doing
this because she knows I'm a fan of wait
I was right but she's just a nothing I'm
addicted look how many I've still got to
eat and I go three and one ray Baba 36
more to go and I am feeling sick if
you're wondering attack one more all
gone
yeah my tongues like little brown oh I
wonder how many animal feeds I reason I
hope you've enjoyed this episode as much
as I have enjoyed making it
wait goodbye